[Musique]
les sénateurs
agissent lundi 23 octobre 2023 députés
et sénateurs sont parvenu à un accord
sur le projet de loi pour le plein
emploi dans le cadre de la commission
mixte
paritaire ce projet de loi a pour
ambition de réduire le taux de chômage à
5 % à l'horizon 2027 contre 7,1 %
aujourd'hui
à cette fin le texte vise à renforcer
l'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
et des bénéficiaires du revenu de
solidarité
active le compromis entre les deux
chambres reprend la plupart des apports
du Sénat la commission mixte paritaire a
ainsi adopté la disposition d'origine
sénatoriale prévoyant que le contrat
d'engagement conclu avec le demandeur
d'emploi ou le bénéficiaire du RSA devra
définir une durée d'activité
hebdomadaire d'au moins 15 he cette
durée d'activité qui compr prendra
notamment des actions de formation et
d'accompagnement pourra être aménagé
pour des raisons liées à la situation
individuelle de
l'intéressé le texte de compromis a
retenu une autre disposition importante
introduite par le Sénat la préservation
dans les missions du réseau pour
l'emploi des prérogatives des
collectivités territoriales et des
opérateurs sur le
territoire les acteurs nationaux et
locaux définiront ainsi de manière
concertée les modalités de leur action
coordonnées sans être contraint par une
charte de coopération inscrite dans la
loi parallèlement le Sénat s'est attaché
à consolider le rôle des communes dans
la gouvernance de l'accueil des jeunes
enfants tout en garantissant que cela
n'entraînera pas de contraintes
excessives pour les petites communes
ainsi modifié ce texte permettra de
renforcer les obligations et les droits
des demandeurs d'emploi tout en
favorisant une meilleure collaboration
entre les acteurs dans le respect des
libertés locales jeudi 9 novembre le
Sénat se prononcera en séance publique
sur les conclusions de la commission
mixte
paritaire pour en savoir plus consultez
le site Internet du
Sénat